okay we are back for another episode i
just got some pre-workout in me and i've
got as much energy as a silverback
gorilla
um today we're going to be talking about
angela merkel trees aka merkle trees
they're not actually named after her
so let's go ahead and get into that
because i want to get myself to the gym
okay so merkle trees what are they
merkle trees are really just an
algorithm that easily allows you to
compute uh basically a set of
differences over two similar sets of
records they do this really quickly and
efficiently using basically something
known as a hash tree and what this goes
ahead and is really useful for are
things like a git version control system
or an
anti-entropy process in some sort of
leaderless database like cassandra or
dynamodb and also in blockchain or
decentralized currencies basically
anytime you need to calculate the
difference between two things and
ultimately attempt to rectify them by
sending some changes over a network a
merkle tree is extremely useful for
allowing you to calculate the smallest
unit of difference between two
two sets of records
so let's look at the basic algorithm for
a merkle tree so we have these four
files here a b c and d and the first
thing we're going to do is go ahead and
calculate some hashes for them and these
are going to be the leaf nodes in our
tree
so i'm going to put these leaf nodes
down here and now every single parent
node of any node is going to basically
incorporate the two hashes into its own
hash and go ahead and use that so
basically to get the hashes of the
parent node i would say concatenate
those two strings of each child node and
then go ahead and take the hash of that
we would do the same thing all the way
up to the root now imagine i wanted to
make a change to one of the files so i'm
going to change c dot txt so you can see
that the hash of c dot txt has changed
thus changing that leaf node thus
changing the parent node and ultimately
changing the root
so now after i make that change if i
want to go ahead and compare the
previous merkle tree with the current
merkle tree to kind of see what file
actually changed i would do the
following
i would go ahead and look at these two i
would say okay well the roots different
so i know that i have a difference
between them somewhere i'm going to have
to traverse that then i would say okay
the right node or the right child of the
root is different so i'm going to have
to traverse the right path and then
ultimately that child of 93 pq versus
4w12 is different and so that's where
the differences lie between the two and
so you know if i wanted to kind of
propagate that change over the network
now as opposed to having to propagate
every single file and go ahead and do
this kind of naive implementation where
we waste a ton of network bandwidth i
can only go ahead and
propagate the change file and even still
there are optimizations to be made even
beyond that where you basically only
propagate the differences of the file
and that's kind of what git does where
you know you have the original file but
then git calculates the diffs and then
the diffs are propagated over the
network but you use the merkle tree to
actually go ahead and calculate where
the diffs are in the first place
okay
so how do merkle trees actually work in
git well it's a little bit different
than what i just showed in the sense
that git is a versioning system which
means that we want to be able to look at
old commits as well as opposed to just
seeing the updated merkle tree of any
state because it's important to be able
to kind of go back in time
so in order to do this what we actually
do is every single file that gets
changed almost gets treated like its own
file and we go ahead and take the hash
of it so if the hash is in the merkle
tree even if it's under a different name
like it has some different metadata we
just go ahead and don't change anything
and you know that's efficient but if
there is a new hash that we go ahead and
do is instead of modifying the old hash
that it corresponds to we go ahead and
add it as a leaf to the merkle tree and
then create this entirely new branch of
that merkle tree and ultimately go up
and propagate those changes all the way
to the root however the new root that
we're creating and all those new
intermediate nodes that we're creating
are all going to be copies we're not
actually modifying the old merkle tree
and what that means is that if we're to
use an old pointer to a root uh
representing an old commit we can still
go ahead and access those old hashes to
the files and go ahead and retrieve the
prior versions of those files
okay
in cassandra we have anti-entropy so
merkle trees are really useful for
basically going ahead and determining
the differences between two replicas as
a result
determining you know the basically the
smallest unit of change that can be sent
over the network and then doing so in
order to ensure that they are eventually
consistent with one another however if
you think about this for a second
there's a little bit of an issue
isn't the data actually always going to
be changing so as a result you might go
ahead and perform anti-entropy and by
the time the data gets there it's
already stale
so
that could be the case however cassandra
actually does this
anti-entropy process not on the raw data
itself not on the keys and values but
instead on those immutable ss table
files that are part of cassandra's lsm
tree based architecture
so this is something known as
incremental read repair basically
cassandra uses immutable ss table files
and as a result
if two replicas have kind of these
similar ss table files and they have yet
to be repaired we can basically just go
ahead and repair an ss table file once
because we know that once all of those
replicas have agreed on the ss table
file
the fact that it's immutable means there
will be no further changes to it and as
a result we're not going to have to
perform anti-entropy multiple times per
the ss table so as a result we can start
marking off all of these access tables
as repaired and then once they've been
repaired we can go ahead and compact
them in the background because we're
gonna get you know consistency between
all of these replicas so instead what we
actually do is instead of sending an
entire merkle tree that represents the
contents of every single ss table we do
this incremental read repair where we're
sending these smaller merkle trees over
the network only representing the
contents of these unrepaired ss tables
and as a result of that we've lowered
the overhead and the the network
bandwidth and i o that needs to be used
so this makes everything more efficient
another thing that has to happen here as
a result of having these two types of ss
tables both unrepaired and repaired is
the compaction process between them kind
of needs to be separated
for example if we have a bunch of
repaired ss tables and then we were to
go ahead and kind of perform log
compaction and merge those in with a
bunch of unre unrepaired ss tables well
then we would have all these keys uh
mixed into our previously repaired ss
table that now perhaps may not be valid
so now we're going to have to perform
sorry not compaction but rather
anti-entropy all over again on something
that we've already performed
anti-entropy on so the way the cassandra
tries to mitigate this problem which is
pretty smart is that it has two types of
compaction basically you can compact
unrepaired esses tables with one another
and you can compact repaired ss tables
with one another and by doing this we
make sure that we're never performing
duplicate anti-entropy by making sure
that basically once an access table has
been repaired that data is never going
to be sent in a merkle tree over the
network again
okay so in conclusion merkle trees are a
really cool way of detecting the
differences between two sets of records
using a hash tree so obviously we can
kind of detect those differences in
logarithmic time by basically just going
ahead and traversing down the tree once
we've figured out those differences it
allows us to kind of send that minimal
unit of you know file diffs over the
network and it greatly makes things a
lot more efficient
we can see these come up in a decent
amount of system design problems such as
you know git revision control systems
and in addition anti-entropy or
blockchain even though i'm not going to
talk about the applications of merkle
trees in blockchain at the moment i am
planning on doing some sort of
blockchain or d5 video in the future
and hopefully we'll be able to kind of
see how merkle trees come into play then
all right guys i hope this one was
useful and i'm going to get myself to
the gym so have